chloe we've seen rob moore in the last
few seasons what made him want to come
back to the show
i think he just needed a break the
kardashians are opening up about their
brother rob who has become
more reclusive in recent years case in
point the 34 year old reality star's
absence during part two of the keeping
up with the kardashians reunion special
which aired sunday on e when host andy
cohen
asked about rob's role on the show
taking a back seat
only briefly appearing during the 20th
and final season
chloe had this to say it's not so much
about physical appearance it's a lot of
how he felt internally about
some of the women in his life and how
they treated him or how he felt
they might have used him to get to
certain
areas or levels and i think that really
affected him because my brother is such
a lover and has like
the most incredible heart and
personality um
and i think he's just getting stronger
and i think you you have to get
heartbroken and you
learn from your mistakes and i think
he's just stronger and feeling better to
be around to be more vulnerable or
exposed he definitely is more low-key
than all of us and we love that and
respect that
rob stepped back from the spotlight
several years ago
after intense scrutiny surrounding his
health and appearance
i am gaining a grip of weight and it's
just depressing
i don't know what to do that's not good
as for how rob
is doing today chloe praises her younger
brother for his progress
i know rob is really feeling really good
about himself right now and he's working
really hard
on himself and so i think before he did
something like this where he has to
address
probably the part that made him want to
take a break
he can start fresh yes i just want rob
to do what's best for him and what makes
him happy and if that makes him happy
then we will all support him
another reason behind rob's low public
profile
his public fallout with blac chyna his
former fiance
and mother of his four-year-old daughter
dream yo
you have serious anger issues
how am i gonna grab yourself why are you
yelling you psycho what's wrong with you
look cause it's aggravating
it must be hard co-parenting
for him with someone who's suing his
entire family
you know i'm sure it is but we could
only imagine how hard that is and
he i know he feels really guilty about
that so none of us ever make him
feel bad about it and dream is honestly
one of the most
incredible little girls in the entire
world and we
never blur the two we separate
completely and we respect that chyna is
the mother of dream and will always
respect
um that that's her position and and so
we never try to
bleed that or make rob feel any more
guilty because that's out of his control
but things are looking up coco even
confirms that rob
is putting himself out there again is he
dating
yes oh he is oh that's great i mean i
was gonna suggest malika and rob
been there done that in march a source
opened up to e.t about the arthur george
sock designer
revealing he's in a really great place
adding that because of dream
rob vowed to start living a healthier
lifestyle quote
after his daughter was born he committed
to taking better care of his health so
he could have the energy to keep
up with her and the benefits of that are
visible
he looks good and seems happy this
wasn't about a quick fix
he's doing terrific robert's good yeah
he's working out and eating good
and so he's on a good path right now
fans will recall
rob lived with chloe and her ex-husband
lamar odom while the couple was filming
their spin-off series
they've since divorced but chloe was
there for lamar
after he overdosed in 2015. where do
things stand with the two of you
today are you in touch at all no we're
not in touch but
i honestly wish i'm nothing but the best
in good health and i'm i think we're all
like really rooting for him and just
want the best for him